>> BREAKING TONIGHT THE WAR ON
COPS IS FAR FROM OVER, SHERIFF
DEPUTY WAS SHOT IN NORTH
CAROLINA TODAY DURING A TRAFFIC
STOP CURRENTLY IN STABLE
CONDITION.
THE SUSPECT IS IN CUSTODY.
WE'RE MONITORING THIS STORY AND
WE'LL BRING YOU UPDATES AS THEY
COME IN.
THIS AS THE MOST LIBERAL CITIES
IN AMERICA CONTINUE TO BE STAND
BY DESTRUCTIVE POLICY.
MANHATTAN D.A. IVAN AT IT AGAIN
AS HE REDUCE CHARGES FOR A
BRAZEN CAREER CROOK WHEN ROB
INNOCENT WOMAN IN NEW YORK CITY
AND SOURCES SAY THAT MURDER TOLD
ARRESTED OFFICER, QUOTE, NECKS
TIME I WON'T DO IT RIGHT IN
FRONT OF YOU.
CRIMINALS ARE ACTUALLY MOCKING
US AT THIS POINT.
NOW WITH REACTION TO ALL OF THIS
ORDER OF POLICE AND VICE
PRESIDENT SERGEANT JOE.
SERGEANT THANKS SO MUCH FOR
JOINING CROSS COUNTRY AGAIN, I
WANT YOU TO COMMENT ON OFFICER
THAT WAS SHOT EARLIER TODAY.
BUT THE FACT THAT THE CRIMINALS
ARE NOW MAKING FUN OF THE ENTIRE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO THEM?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW LET ME START
WITH THIS SERGEANT THAT WAS SHOT
MY THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS ARE WITH
HIM AND MY HEARTBREAKS FOR HIM
AND HIS FEMALE TO DEAL WITH ALL
OF THAT BUT WHAT'S BECOMING TOO
FAMILIAR PATTERN WE HAVE 326
POLICE OFFICERS SHOT LAST YEAR
THAT WAS A RECORD SINCE WE
STARTED TRACKING THIS YEAR AND
THIS YEAR 60 POLICE OFFICERS
SHOT WHICH IS 60.INCREASE OVER
LAST YEAR.
AND YOU KNOW I'M GOING TO PUT MY
UNIFORM ON IMMEDIATELY AFTER
THIS AND GO OUT ON PATROL.
BUT YOU KNOW BEFORE I DO I'M
GOING TO TELL MY OFFICERS MAKE
SURE YOU'RE CAREFUL THROUGHOUT
BECAUSE CRIMINALS ARE THINKING
LESS AND LESS OF SHOOTING US.
AND THEY'RE THINKING LESS AND
LESS OF KILLING US BECAUSE THEY
KNOW THEY'RE NOTS HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR ACTION YET
WE HEAR FROM ACADEMIC AND
JOURNALIST SAYING YOUR JOUR JOB
IS NOT THAT DANGEROUS ONCE YOU
SIT YOUR ASS NEXT TO ME THAT
THAT PATROL KARL AND YOU SEE IF
MY JOB IS DANGEROUS.
AS FAR AS BRAGG IS THERE SOMEONE
MORE OUT OF TOUCH WITH NEW YORK
CITIERS THAN D.A. BRAGG AND HIS
STAFF IN RECENT WIN PACK POLL
SAID 74% NEW YORKERS SAW CRIME
AS A PROBLEM AND IN D.A. TRUST
THINKS WE SHOULD GO SOFTER ON
CRIME TO TALK ABOUT CRIMINAL YOU
MENTION THAT GUY HAS BEEN
ARRESTED 46 TIMES.
46!
AND HE WAS OUT ON PAROLE WHEN HE
DID THIS GRAND LARCENY AND D.A.
THINK IT IS A GREAT IDEA TO
REDUCE CHARGE.
YOU DO NOT CUT A DEAL WITH A
REPEAT FELON LIKE THIS.
SH AND WHAT IT REALLY TELLS THE
COMMUNITY AND WHAT IT EL IT IS
VICTIMS IS THEY'LL GIVE A DAMN
ABOUT YOU IT TELLS COPS WE DON'T
CARE ABOUT RISK YOU'RE TAKING TO
ALL OF YOUR VIEWERS IF YOU HAVE
PEOPLE POLITICIANS IN YOUR
COMMUNITY THAT ARE NOT EMBRACING
LAWS AND ORDER YOU NEED TO GET
LOUD AND TALK ABOUT IT.
YOU NEED TO HOD THEM ACCOUNTABLE
AND VOTE THEM OUT BECAUSE
CONSEQUENCES ARE DEADLY.
LAWRENCE: I THOUGHT WHOLE POINT
OF CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM WAS
WHEN CIVIL LIBERTY WERE VIOLATED
OR WHEN CRIMINALS REFORM
THEIRIVE LOOS --
BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT'S HAPPENING
IN PROGRESSIVE CITY THESE PEOPLE
CONTINUE THEY HAVE WRAP SHEETS
LONGER THAN CVS RECEIPTS.
SO IT IS VERY SAD WHAT'S
HAPPENING TO COUNTRY BUT I WANT
TO GET YOUR REACTION TO THIS.
THIS IS WIFE OF ALBUQUERQUE
COP --
THAT HAD SOME FIRED UP RHETORIC
FOR THOSE LEADERS THAT AREN'T
DOING ANYTHING ABOUT THIS.
WATCH.
. STEADILY GOTTEN WORSE OVER
LAST TO YEARS AND IT'S BECAUSE
OF THE POLITICS.
IT IS THE CHOICES --
THAT THEY'VE MADE TO THROW OUR
OFFICERS AWAY.
LAWRENCE: WHAT'S YOUR REACTION
SERGEANT?
>> I'LL TELL YOU IT IS
HEARTBREAKING TO HEAR HER TALK
ABOUT BUT THAT'S WHAT WE NEED.
WE NEED EVERY AMERICAN IN THIS
COUNTRY TO STAND UP AND FIGHT
AGAINST THESE WOKE POLICIES
BECAUSE WE KNOW THEY'RE ON
MITIGATED DISEASE.
JUST IN ALBUQUERQUE ALONE THEY
WERE ONE OF 16 AMERICAN CITIES
WHO EXPERIENCE THEIR HIGHEST
MURDER RATE ON RECORD.
ON RECORD!
AND YOU'RE THINKING TO DONGT TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH POLICY AND IT
IS KILLING OUR COMMUNITIES NOT
SAYING WE'RE FIGHT FOR FOR SOUL
OF OUR COUNTRY RIGHT NOW YOU
KNOW WHAT WORST PART OF IT IS
WE'RE NOT DOING CRIMINALS A
FAVOR JUST MAYBE IF WE WERE HARD
ON THEM LIKE YOU WERE TALKING
ABOUT EARLIER ON THE HOMELESS
SITUATION, IF WE TOOK A HARD
LIEN WITH SOME OF THESE FOLKS
MAYBE THEY WOULD ACTUALLY
STRAIGHTEN UP.
MAYBE ACTUALLY WE WOULD GET THEM
ON THE RIGHT PATH.
BUT YOU SAW FROM THE CAREER
CRIMINAL, WELL, HOPEFULLY NEXT
TIME NOBODY WILL SEE ME DOING IT
AND I'LL GET AWAY WITH IT AND
THAT'S ATTITUDE AND IT NEEDS TO
STOP.
LAWRENCE: SERGEANT UNTIL THESE
FOLKS HIT ROCK BOTTOM THEY
WOAPGHT CHANGE THEIR LIVES
THAT'S FIRST JOB IN A JUVENILE
COURT I'M TELLING YOU I KNOW IT